Okay. So, welcome everyone to the 12th
lecture of the course which also happens
to be my final lecture on the next week
and the week after. David Grabber, one
of my PhD students, he's going to teach
you about AI for chemistry and biology.
Okay. So, let's uh proceed.
So what we have learned so far means um
this has been going on for a long time
but we have what we are essentially
trying to do
this yeah is to learn PTE using neural
networks and in particular we have sort
of
reduced the problem to operator learning
which is learning the PD solution
operators from data and we have seen so
many different architectures right
convolutions transformers
we have looked at time dependent
problems with all to-all training. We
have looked at GNN's. We have looked at
graphs plus transformers. And in the
last lecture, we looked at arguably the
hardest PTEs. These are PDS with chaotic
multiscale solutions where we realize
that you need some generative AI, Gen AI
in particular, Gen CFT. So all of this
is in a way telling us that we can use
neural networks, deep learning AI to do
this kind of physics or to learn this
kind of physics. But what is the sort of
the main caveat the final caveat and I
think we have touched on this before but
this is the time to really sort of
double down and understand what's going
on. So what have I showing you here? So
I'm showing you different architectures
right? So here you have CNO I don't know
how well you see it now you see probably
see it better. So here we have CN FNO
rigno this is a graph based architecture
gout which is graphs plus transformers
genf which is what we saw last time. So
these are the different uh plots or
different graphs showing different uh
things on the x-axis this is the same
every time. Okay. And this is the
training data set size. So this is data
size
on the x-axis and the y-axis is some
some version of the error.
So here it's L1 error, L1 error, L1
error. Here is the Wstein distance
because remember that gen CFT it does
not capture an individual
uh field. It captures a distribution of
a field. So you have to put some
probability some distances or you cannot
have a norm on probability measures but
you can have distances. And this is a
Wstein distance. Okay, the details of
these plots are not important. Right? So
what we are studying here is a very
important question which is what happens
when we increase the size of the data
set. Right? And as you can see from the
plots uh that in each of these all of
these cases and this is true for all the
architectures that you have seen for all
the problems we have studied what you
have is the following behavior. Let's
focus on one of them. Let's look at CNO.
This is the one in blue. This was for
the sheer layer right this 2D problem
that we have looked at extensively. So
what do we observe that if you have 512
samples in the training set the error is
about 4 1/2%. Then if you have uh
something like,024 samples the error
goes down to 3 1/2%. If you have uh four
times that 4,96 samples the error is
about 2 1/2% and the error is close to
1% when you have about 10,000 samples.
Right? So this is sort of the story that
you get. It's the same here. Same kind
of story, different data sets. You start
with 2% and you go down uh to about 1%
of error. Similarly here, here also same
kind of a behavior. So what do we learn
here? We see that at least empirically
that the error whatever be the type of
error, it could be L1, L2, it could be
distributional, whatever be the type of
error is scaling with respect to data
set size. Okay. So n is the size of the
data set. As we increase the number of
samples, our models get more and more
and more accurate. This is not
surprising because we can even prove at
least some of this theoretically. So
these are I'm not having the time to
discuss this in detail. This is what is
called uh generalization error, analysis
of generalization error. Here are a
couple of papers where we have done this
for operator learning. Other people have
also done this. So essentially the idea
is that you can you can essentially
prove this and you always see it in
practice as you increase the size of the
data set your error becomes better and
better and better. So it means that you
know to get more accur there are some
saturation right eventually you cannot
train the model beyond a certain limit
but up to that saturation you can
essentially train the model. Okay so
this is roughly the idea that we have
but the point that is important here is
what is the rate of this decrease? We
know that the error decreases but what
is the rate of this decrease actually
from the ballpark you can easily see it
what the rate is going to be roughly
speaking so remember that we were uh
let's say when when are we at 2% error
so 2% error is roughly with uh I don't
know 2,000 samples is it yeah and 1%
error is roughly with 8,000 samples
right so the error reduces by a factor
of two if you increase the samples by a
factor of roughly four it's a little bit
more than four because as you can see
here the error is not yet 1%. And you
can keep on doing this analysis over and
over again it's the same story here. So
if you have a error of about yeah this
is difficult maybe this is around 1 and
a half%. And if you increase it by a
factor of four the error goes by a
factor of two. So you can see it again
and again and again that the error
decreases but actually the upper bound
one can prove this even rigorously is
given by half. You know this is
essentially central limit theorem law of
large numbers when you sample from a
random distribution where the accuracy
or the integration error reduces as a
square root of the number of samples. In
practice it's a little bit there's an
upper bound in practice it's a little
bit less than that. So let's say 0.45 or
0.43. This is more or less a universal
number. It could be within that range
0.4 to 0.5. Okay. So what is the
implication of that? The implication of
that is that in order to get acceptable
errors now depending on the applications
uh engineering applications the best you
can hope for is 1%. Okay 1% is the magic
number anywhere between 1 and 10% is
acceptable in engineering. Okay. And 1%
means that if you 1% is uh rel relative
error is 1 over 100. And to get one over
100 if things scale by fact square root
it's the square of 100 which is 10,000
samples. And this is exactly what you
see here. So in this particular case to
get 1% error you need about 10,000
samples. Here uh it's a bit better with
uh this particular data set is probably
a very easy one. Yeah. SVS. So sinosural
vortex se sheet you can get 1% with
thousand samples but uh you know it
depends on the application that you have
for instance some of these data sets you
are already at 4% at th00and so you'll
get to 1,000 and 10,000 it's 1%. So what
is the story here the story is that
these models require big data they
require anywhere between thousand and
10,000 samples per task in order to get
acceptable errors. is not surprising,
right? Machine learning is all about
data. More data you give, the better
your model is, more skill it has, more
robust it is and so on. That's well and
good. And particularly if you're dealing
with text or uh images or video, this is
not a challenge at all, right? Because
you can just scoop all the data that you
have on the internet. You can just do a
common crawl and get all the data text
data. You can go through archive. You
can get scientific literature. You can
go through all the digital libraries and
you can get a lot of uh text data. And
this is why large language models are so
successful because they have been able
to gather a lot of data. For videos or
images, you just again go through the
internet common shutter stock or YouTube
or whatever means there are different
sources. But now for physics on the
other hand, this is very very difficult,
right? because this was our fundamental
challenge that in order to the whole
reason or one of the reasons why I want
to do machine learning is because it's
expensive to generate this kind of
training data. Now remember that uh I
think I showed you one extreme example
which was 61,000
u
node hours per single sample right so
just imagine if you have to generate
10,000 of that that's just prohibitive
the cost is prohibitive and even with
the best code that you have recently I I
wrote something on archive you can see
it it's uh it takes about hundreds of
millions of dollars to generate this
data this is uh you need billions of
dollars to generate the data to train
these models
So we cannot afford this. Not everyone
has those billion. Jeff Bezos has he has
a company now to do this. But uh most
most people most universities most
companies don't have that kind of money
or that kind of u bandwidth ability to
do this right. So we have to make our
models more data efficient. And this is
the fundamental caveat. Right? So with a
lot of effort the community is able to
build models that given data are very
good at task specific jobs right we
showed that in time and again time and
again in different applications but
whenever you don't have enough data this
is a struggle when you have data it
works very well weather is a prime
example you have a lot of weather data
so the AI weather systems are very very
good high energy physics is another
example if you go to CERN they have a
lot of data so there it's of course very
very advantageous but for most
applications in physics this is not the
case. So we have to make our models data
efficient. We have to rely on less data.
Instead of 10,000 we have to go down to
100 or one day to 10. But at the moment
this is still quite a bit of a dream.
But is this point very clear? So this is
the main obstacle that we have towards
the deployment of uh ML systems today in
physics or in in these domains questions
and one of the reasons for instance in
chemistry alpha fold the reason why
alpha fold took off is because there was
a huge database protein database PDB and
then they were able to train their
models on that database because people
had um they had collected this data
there was a lot of experimental data
they had put it in one place and that's
why alpha fold could be trained and Deis
Hassavves and John Jumper could win the
Nobel Prize. If that data was not there,
nothing could be done, right? So other
people paved the way for them. But in
this domain, there is no such data
except the cases weather, maybe
astronomy, there is quite a bit of data
around and high energy physics. Apart
from these domains, the amount of data
is not publicly available. You know,
private companies have data, but other
than that, it's not available. Any
questions on this point? This is the
fundamental issue. No. Okay. So, how do
we solve this data efficiency, right?
You can argue and sometimes it's also
called complexity with respect to
samples uh sample complexity. You can we
can go back to pins. If you remember in
pins, we did not need any data
whatsoever, right? Because we could just
work with uh with PTE residuals. So, you
could say why don't we revisit that,
right? So remember that if you have a
PTE
and you have the solution operator of
the PTE. So given the input f you were
able to put out the output U and then
you draw the data distribution on the
input and the idea was to learn this uh
push forward right so then given given
the data we wanted to learn this also
given the PD right means we assume that
we know the PD exactly or PTE exactly
which is not always the case. So in
principle what you could do is by the
way there's a typo here this should be y
okay uh in principle what you could do
is you take your operator learning
architecture CNO fno vit whatever you
have the data term right so you have the
data fidelity term and in addition you
could also add a pd residual term you
can say that okay you have the data that
we try to fit in a supervised manner but
also these are neural networks at the
end of the A. So in principle we can
take their derivatives. These are
functions. The inputs and outputs are
functions. We can take the derivatives.
We can form the PD residual.
And this is not pins but it is a cousin
or a daughter of pins. It's called
physics informal operators or penos.
Okay. So this is the this is the story.
This is one way right because in
principle in pins we realize that we
don't need any data. If you have the
form of the PTE, we could just use that.
But of course, we know that this leads
to nowhere, right? Because the reason
why and people have done quite a bit of
work on this, but whatever you do,
remember that this doesn't work, right?
Because even for simple problems like
adection, even when the probability
measure is a dra, right? So if mu is
equal to delta of some f, it's
concentrated on a single function, this
does not work. And actually when you
have this operator centric perspective
this becomes very very very hard because
the state-of-the-art in this is that you
have you need preconditioners. This is
what I tried to teach you. You need
preconditioners and these
preconditioners work if the inputs and
outputs are low dimensional. For
instance the input are spatial and time
coordinates and the output is a scalar
value or a small vector. So this works
but for operators you know that the
inputs outputs are infinite dimensional.
No one at the moment knows how to
precondition this. So this simply does
not work right. Uh one day maybe we'll
figure out how to do this. Many people
are including us are actively working on
this. But at the moment this does not
work. Okay. So this is not the way to
go. Uh but there is maybe there will be
some exercise on physics and formal
operators where we we try to teach you
why they may or may not work. So in the
absence of that what do we do means uh
we we go back to the drawing board. This
is a bit dated because now we have GPT5
and so on. But uh the point is if you
look at the most impressive AI models
and this is clearly the GPT class models
or Gemini or Claude whatever the the the
the topofthe-line uh LLMs or multimodal
LLMs and these systems of course they
are able to do this very very well. So
what do I mean by that? Of course you
can say they are trained on lots of data
but what is interesting is not just the
amount of data that they trained on
which is of course enormous but the fact
is if you think of chat GPD right now
chat GPT has been trained on huge
amounts of data but at the same time
when we try to deploy it and when we ask
give it a prompt which it has never seen
before which might not be in the
training set at all it is still able to
give you information right particularly
if you provide some context you provide
a informative prompt. So in some sense
what chat GPT does is that even though
it has been trained at a very large
scale in principle it's always operating
out of distribution because uh you can
always come up with that prompt which
might not be in the training data and
you give it some information and it
provides you with reasonable answers. Of
course, now with reasoning models, this
is even more pertinent. And the reason
why modern AI systems are able to deal
with this data challenge because
essentially a prompt is very very little
amounts of data is because they are what
are called foundation models and this is
what I'm going to discuss almost this
entire lecture. So what are foundation
models? Now foundation models are the
base of modern machine learning. They
came in about 3 4 years ago, right? Not
that not that long. And the idea behind
a foundation model is that there are two
stages to a foundation model. One is
called pre-training.
So I will of course define it uh later.
So during pre-training what a foundation
model does something like chat GPT does
is that you go through enormous amounts
of data. Okay, enormous amounts of data.
This could be multimodal in this case it
is text, images, speech, um I don't
know, 3D signals whatever all kinds of
different kinds of data. And within text
uh it can be all kinds of text. It can
be comic books. It can be great
literature. It can be English, French,
Russian, German, whatever. It can be it
can be code. It can be math whatever all
different kinds of text all different
kinds of uh images and so on. So it is
trained on a very very large and very
diverse. So it's not just large but
diverse
corpus.
And this is sort of the key to a
foundation model that it has a very
large pre-training database and very
diverse pre-training database and this
goes into a big transformer. Usually
it's a transformer. You'll see some
reasons later why that is the case. But
uh you can have any model there. So if
you change transformer to something
else, this will still be valid. But then
comes the second stage which is what is
called finetuning. Now in fine-tuning
what you do is that you take this very
very large model which has been trained
to learn language for instance and not
just any kind of all universal human
language or natural language as it is
called and then you can focus on some
specific things like captioning an image
for instance or just understanding texts
in a remote language like Roman and so
on. So in this case what happens is you
take the large model and you specialize
it for a particular task. So this is uh
diverse and multitask
and this is sort of task specific.
I will of course define these words very
well. And what chat GPT or chatbots do
AI chatbots do is that they specialize
it so much that you don't need to
fine-tune. You essentially can prompt
them. So prompting is sort of what is
called in context learning. you don't
you don't change the weights but you're
able to sort of slightly tune the model
just from the information the context
that is provided. So this is sort of the
let's say the thing in machine learning
now that you train on very very large
amounts of data, massive amounts of
data, very diverse data. You take the
model, it learns something useful
representations usually and then you
sort of deploy it for some specific
models. Right? So this is why chat GPT
works. This is why uh image generators,
video generators, world models, they all
work. They follow exactly the same
paradigm. It turns out what we are doing
fits this paradigm very very well. Okay,
let me just explain it and then uh then
we will sort of elaborate on this. So in
principle you can imagine physics of all
types engineering chemistry everything
is included in that that each of these
are specific systems. For instance the
flow of air or the flow of sound inside
this room is specific system. The
weather outside could be a specific
system something else could be a
specific system and so on. So we assume
that these are modeled by different
types of PDEs. So this could be for
instance LLAS, this could be wave, this
could be Navia Stokes and so on and so
forth, right? This could be oiler
and there are hundreds or thousands of
these potential PDEs and combinations of
them because you have systems of PDS and
so on. Now for each of these specific
PDEs there would be different operators
and to generate different operators what
do we can do? We can vary initial
conditions, boundary conditions, um
coefficients,
forcing and so on. Right?
So all these can be varied. Each of
these variations, each of these measure
that we are going to define leads to a
different operator. So in principle, we
have infinitely many physical systems,
infinitely many operators corresponding
to each physical system. And this
provides us with a very very rich uh
vocabulary in some sense. So you can
imagine each PD is a library and inside
each library there are millions of books
right which are of different types for
instance.
So now uh each time you need the PDEs
and the data and what we need to do is
we need to think of it in these two
stages. Stage one is pre-training which
is in orange and stage two is finetuning
which is in magenta. So for instance
what I can do is that I can say okay I'm
going to pre-train my machine learning
system AI system on so just for
concreteness here on the laplas and the
wave equation okay just two two PDEs
this can be finitely many but large
number and within that I choose certain
operators so this could be I have some
specific boundary conditions specific
domains and so on and then I choose a
couple of operators here one operator
here and this is my pre-tra training
data I train the model on that right but
the whole point of the model is not in
the pre-training it's in the finetuning
and this can be done for instance in the
same kind of physics but with different
distributions or it can be something
completely new like Navia Stokes which
the model has never seen before and this
kind of a separation and distillation is
um sort of very typical of what a
foundation model looks like. So you can
really build a foundation model or at
least in principle it's very tempting to
build a foundation model with just this
kind of principles but this is uh very
high level picture right are there any
questions here so that I can explain it
uh better because I need some feedback
if you understand or not questions
everybody understood yes
>> in which form do you give the like
>> you don't even need to give the at the
moment no one is able to give the
symbolic form of the PD
But you can in principle but at the
moment it's not necessary at the moment.
Remember that so far in this datadriven
paradigm we have never really used the
specific form of the PD at all right we
we give it some inputs this could be
initial conditions boundary conditions
whatever coefficients and then we
provide some kind of an output okay so
we don't need necessarily need to do
that but that's that could also come in
the future
further questions no okay so let's see
so this seems very tempting right we
have so many PDEs we have data in the
course itself we have seen different
kinds kinds of data sets, different
kinds of ees. Can we build such a
foundation model and does it work on
downstream tasks?
Okay, so let's see. So can it work? Uh
this is uh very doubtful. Maybe I
directly go to the next uh slide because
yeah
now for those who have done basic math
and physics also in engineering and you
go to a course doing PDS or ODS for that
matter you will think that this is
simply not going to work because what do
we if you take up any textbook right
then you see that PDS are classified
into different types you have elliptic
parabolic hyperbolic you have time
dependent time independent
you have different kinds of equations,
Llas, heat, wave, Navia Stokes. You have
different techniques for each of these
equations, different kinds of behavior,
different kinds of numerical methods. So
in some sense, you can think of each of
these PTEs or PD systems as being
islands. Okay, literally my library
analogy means these are libraries which
have no books in common potentially. You
know, they're far from each other. Maybe
one is a library here in Jude, another
is in Paris hundreds of years ago. They
have no books in common.
presumably right and this is the so you
have different kinds of islands
different silos and they don't talk to
each other
the question that naturally arises is
that whenever you have to pre-train a
model you can only do it on a finite set
of these right you cannot data in nature
is finite right so you can only do it on
a finite and that would be a small set
could be a very small set and also the
amount of data distributions the number
of books that you can collect from each
library is finite. So you have a very
sort of a small sort of sampling of this
entire vast universe of data that is out
there. But can it really learn the
effective representations and generalize
particularly to unseen and unrelated PDS
right so this is sort of the key point
so if I have lelass and wave equation I
train my model on that and then can I do
fluid dynamics or structural mechanics
or whatever aerospace engineering or
whatever robotics. So this is the
question. It seems unlikely, right?
Because the phenomena are so different.
If you think of diffusion, things spread
out. If you think of transport, things
move. You know, if you think of
electromagnetics, there's a magnetic
field and things move according to the
magnetic field. And in diffusion, it's
completely different. Things just
disperse out. How can these things be
sort of related to each other? I mean,
this seems to be the sort of a question.
And there is a it's a it's a legitimate
it's it's a valid question. But unless
until we build uh we cannot answer this
question. So in the last couple of years
I would say the community as a whole has
started building this models and the one
that I will describe is our own model.
Uh because I think it's still
state-of-the-art uh despite what some
other people claim but uh it's still
state-of-the-art or it's near
state-of-the-art at least it
demonstrates that this can be done. It
was sometime last year in fact when I I
I even taught it last year and it was
released approximately a year ago a
little more than a year ago. It's called
Prooseidon. So what does Poseidon do?
And this is the model as I said uh you
can you can find it. You can even uh
play with it. It's available in hugging
face. It's the the paper is already
available and it essentially does this.
Right? So the idea is that we make some
simplifications because uh you can't do
everything at one go. So we say we
restrict ourselves to 2D mean this was
the starting point 2D and we restrict at
that time one year ago the the progress
in terms of uh doing sort of
unstructured grids was much less. Today
we have that ability but even one year
ago I would say that this was not the
case. So just to sort of kick things off
we restricted ourselves to 2D to cartian
grids. Okay. And the fine-tuning we do
on some other grids, but during
pre-training we do it on cartisian
grids. And I will sort of walk you
through this model which does exactly
this. It picks a few PTEs, a few
operators from these PTEs, pre-trains a
model and then it tries to fine-tune it
and sees uh what is the what is the
structure. So you know that with task
specific let let's just let's just go
through it and then things will become
clearer. So the backbone I will come
back to it is going to be a transformer.
uh this we have already seen the
scalable operator transformer. So this
is a swin transformer
and this is mostly for efficiency
reasons right because we know that uh
vision transformers also work equally
well. Just to remind you what what
happens is that given an input field you
go through an embedding you go and use
attention in the swin manner with no
retention uh do it multi-cale because
this is very important you have this
residual connections are convolutions
and then you go to a bottleneck and come
back up right and then you go back. So
this is sort of the idea we have uh time
as a embedding right so time is an
embedding so this is the attention block
so you only attend inside the window and
you shift the windows to attend to those
that you've not attended to before we do
all toall training again something that
is uh so it's time conditioned uh all
these time conditioning is done through
layer norms right this is again a
reminder we have already seen this and
then in all toall training we have
timeepend dependent sequence and what we
can do is we can start at any point and
learn at any future point. So it allows
us to sort of incorporate a lot of data.
But this is a specific model. You can
change the model. Other people have used
other models. Even we have different
models. Now so that is going to be the
backbone. All this data is going to go
into this transformer model and then we
are going to pre-train it. Right? But
the key to a foundation model is not
just the model that underlies it but the
data. In fact, it's really a data
dominated or datadriven regime. So what
is the data? Remember that we at any
time maybe we can increase the scale of
data and we can increase the diversity
but at any time it will still be a
finite set of PDS a finite set of
physics that you can train your model
on. So we chose for different scientific
reasons uh which I can explain to you.
We chose two kinds of remember that
everything is in cartian grades uh 2D.
So we chose two kinds of one kind of
physics but two different regimes. One
was with the incompressible flows and
this is the Navia Stokes equation. So if
you remember this is the Navia Stokes
equation here and there are two data
sets that we chose. One is with uh
essentially sinosoidal initial
conditions uh sine waves as initial
conditions in both the components of the
velocity and this you can see as time
these are different samples as you can
see as time progresses you get this sort
of small scale behavior. Similarly, we
chose with gausians as your initial
conditions. So, this is gausian. And
here you get more large scale flow,
right? So, this is just two operators
that we chose. But for each of them, we
have a lot of trajectories, right?
Earlier we are talking about,000 or
10,000. Here each of this is 20,000
trajectories. So, total of 40,000
trajectories, right? And we have many
many snapshots with all to all training.
This becomes a large volume. This is one
data set or two two data sets
corresponding to one equation. The other
is still fluid flow but now it's the
compressible oiler equations because we
also wanted to capture shock waves,
high-speed flow and so on.
There are four data sets here. So this
is what is called reman problems. This
is what is sheer layer. We have seen
this before in the incompressible case.
Again gausian as before and we have our
own data set. It's called curve reman
problems. Very very complicated initial
data as you can see here. So these are
all sort of spec specifically designed
for this kind of a purpose. So for each
of these data set we have 9 and a half
10,000 trajectories. So total of 80,000
trajectories. Six operators two
equations 80,000 trajectories because
okay you can scale this. Instead of
80,000 you can have a million. Instead
of six you can have 60. Instead of two
you can have 10. But the numbers that
we're talking about are small. We'll
never be able to sample all the physics
that is out there in the universe.
Right? So we have to start somewhere and
the model has to somehow learn from the
data that it is provided to. Then comes
the so this is the details of the
pre-training. So all this data it's in
the form of operators right. So the
inputs are functions outputs are
functions. We were able to feed in into
the transformer and because of all toall
training the number of images was
approximately 5 million images. So it
was quite a bit of uh it was quite a bit
of data at that time. It was the largest
amount of data in terms of the number of
images that is fed into a model. And we
had three different kinds of models. A
small model or tiny model as we call it
tiny 20 million parameters then a base
model which is 160 million parameters
and a large model which is 650 million
parameters. We also had a billion
parameter model but actually as I said
we also had very we have tried on very
large models but we have not deployed
them yet they're expensive and this
model didn't take a lot of time to train
uh it took on on one at that time on one
eight uh one node eight Nvidia RTX 4090s
it took AC approximately a week of
training okay so it was not a huge
amount of compute this changes when you
go to 3D in 3D this is a factor factor
of 100. But at the moment uh this is
what we had as I said even because if
you have very large uh GPUs so GH200 not
100 this takes about a week on Alps this
is the big supercomputer that we have
much bigger models can be trained on
that but at the moment what we have is a
model which has approximately half a
billion closer to 600 700 million
parameters right so there's a very large
model uh not not the easiest to handle
right so that's the model that's the
pre-training data We pre-trained the
model but remember that the pre-training
is not uh the design of the foundation
model. They do the pre-training but
that's not the objective. The objective
of the model is to learn some
representations during pre-training and
then to be useful for fine-tuning.
Right? So this is what why it really
matters. So it's the second stage that
is the real key stage. Once you're
pre-trained, you have to sort of uh
fine-tune. And what did we fine-tune on?
We'll see the results after the break.
So what we chose is a I think an
interesting data set uh of our own. It's
called PD gym. It's also publicly
available. So there are 15 tasks. Uh I
don't know how well you can see but the
maybe the table is better. There are 15
tasks but the point is that these tasks
are uh in a hierarchy. They're arranged
in a hierarchy. As you can see here,
four of these tasks or four of these
operators, each of these tasks is one
specific operator, right? These are with
the Navia Stokes equations. They are
different. They are not in distribution.
They're out of distribution. You'll see
in a in a second how these look like.
But the physics is still Navia Stokes.
Just the initial conditions. The
distribution of the initial conditions
is different. Similarly, we have two
from the Oiler equations. Uh this is um
here. So six of these 15 are different
operators. So you the model has to
generalize. But these are more or less
the physics should not be very very
different because the governing
equations are still the same. So that's
the bottom of the hierarchy. We have six
operators where let's say the physics is
roughly similar to what it is seen
during pre-training. Then we gradually
up the ante. We we increase we add some
extra physics. For instance here we add
transport. Transport was not there in
the in the pre-training set. We add
transport. Then we add forcing. So this
is another example. and we add gravity.
So this is another example. So this was
six was on the base. Then we have three
where we have added to the physics.
Okay. So the base physics is there but
in addition we have added some physical
effects. Then comes the next set of
problems which are completely out of uh
syllabus out of distribution because
these are the wave equation. This is a
propagation of acoustic waves uh not
fluid dynamics and Alen Khan is a
reaction diffusion equation which is
also not fluid dynamics completely
different right so the physics becomes
completely different these are the next
three and the final three are even time
independent remember that my
pre-training data is completely time
dependent but the last set of problems
are even time independent and completely
different physics so this is okay
there's a flow past an air foil but this
is on an unstructured grid even so this
is certainly
far from what the model has seen and
then we have a poso equation and helm's
equation and so on. So you can see that
this is a hierarchical obstacle course
in the beginning the obstacles are easy
because relatively easy because the
physics is potentially similar even
though it's technically out of
distribution then you add a little bit
more then you go to something very
different but still time dependent and
finally we go to something which is even
time independent. Right? So this this is
how a real foundation model will work
like because you'll have some tasks
which are close to your distribution
training distributions some tasks which
will be far away and you have to test
for all of them. Okay so that's the
thing uh here is an example of uh some
fine uh some downstream tasks. So this
is called the sinosidal vortex sheet. Uh
so these are the inputs. This is the uh
horizontal velocity and the vertical
velocity and this is how the ground
truth looks like. So some vortices are
shed and they move around and as you can
see the even though it is Navia Stokes
it is very different from what it had
seen before right because here you don't
see this sort of concentrated vortices
moving around. So this is one example of
a task a downstream task which is let's
say close to what the physics has been
seen. Then you have another one this is
wave equation. So you have this kind of
little earthquakes. They move through
this kind of a medium and these waves
start interacting with each other and
after a while they have this sort of a
behavior. This is very different. This
not fluid flow, right? This is acoustic
wave propagation. So these are the
challenges in front of us. The
pre-trained model has been there. Now it
needs to be fine-tuned. It needs to be
adjusted to the specific tasks. Right?
So but how do we do it? This is what we
will discuss after the break. So let's
take a break now and let's meet at 10.
So we have approximately 12 minutes and
then we will we'll consider it from
there.
Resume the recording. So how do we
fine-tune?
Okay. So let's uh remember let's let's
focus on this picture here. Okay. There
are two two ways but let's focus on this
picture here. So if you remember the
model that we have or all models that we
have they're more or less uh in fact it
might not be a bad idea to spend a bit
of time on this. So if you think of our
models right so whatever Scott it could
be vit it could be co or whatever the
way it works is that you have the input
now the input goes into latent
some latent space then there is uh then
there is some it still goes on in latent
and then it goes into output right
and this is roughly speaking the encoder
And this is the processor
and the decoder. And this is what we
have learned last time. For instance, in
code the encoder and the proc decoder
graphs, but the processor is a
transformer. But in other cases, it
could be convolutions. It could be
transformers, whatever it is, right? And
this is where we have embeddings.
So embeddings are the way in which our
input is translated into a latent space
and this is also some recovery or so you
take the embeddings and then you go back
to the output space right so this is
roughly the basic structure the skeleton
of all the models that we have
considered now right so now the what the
embeddings tell the model is that oh hey
this is the kind of input that we're
looking at maybe it's pressure
temperature,
density, velocity fields, whatever. And
similarly, given the model, all that the
decoder or the recovery layer does is
that it recovers the right variables.
Right? So now there are two ways in
which you can fine-tune the model. So
let's focus on this one. The other one
is pretty obvious and this is what we
call as non-native. Okay, let's start
with the native usage. What does native
usage mean? that the inputs and outputs
are already somehow in the dictionary or
in the model. The model has seen similar
inputs and outputs before. For instance,
the this model has been trained as a
fluid dynamics model, right? So, it has
seen the density, the two velocity
fields and the pressure and the inputs
that you have are exactly the same
density, velocity fields and the
pressure. In that case, what you can do
is that you can transfer all the
parameters of the model, right? So,
maybe I even have some text here. Yes,
exactly. So remember that the model is
given by different kinds of trainable
parameters and you transfer all of it.
So instead of starting maybe I so you
have a model uh let's say u s of theta
right and in gradient descent you start
with uh you always have theta k + 1 is
theta k minus the gradient with respect
to theta of l of theta k. So this is
your gradient descent and there's a
learning rate of course at K. So this is
your gradient descent and you started
earlier theta 0 was random. So we
started randomly with some
initialization her initialization or the
gloro initialization and so on something
that reflects the norm of the inputs
right but now in a foundation model what
you do for down for downstream tasks
downstream tasks or fine-tuning FT so
you zero which is from the foundation
model
from the pre-training so first you have
to pre-train the model and if you going
to deploy it for a fluid dynamics uh
data set then all that you have to do is
to use it for um you just instead of
starting randomly you start at a good
position you think that the model has
learned some physics of fluid dynamics
and it should be able to use that right
so all the all the parameters are
transferred and they are the ones which
are fine-tuned the more interesting case
is the non-native usage non-native usage
it could be for instance for the wave
equation now the inputs are going to be
displacement Right? Because that's what
uh the ground is getting displaced.
That's how the wave is spreading. It
could be a coefficient. Uh perhaps in a
diffusion equation, it could be
something completely different. It could
be the current. It could be the voltage.
Whatever. In this case, we have to
accept that the model has not even seen
this inputs. But on the other hand,
maybe there is some interesting uh
interesting physics that is there in the
latent space. So in this case what you
do is that you transfer but you only
transfer the you you train the embedding
parameters from scratch and the recovery
parameters from scratch. So in other
ways you say that your model theta has
two components theta embedding and theta
latent.
Okay. And then when you do gradient
descent your theta embedding zero
embedding this is rand
uh initialized from scratch and theta
latent is from the uh from the
foundation model. So in other words
you're saying that I allow the model
there are other ways to do this but this
is how this was done here. you allow the
model to learn some inputs and outputs
some basic physics so that it can
represent the inputs and outputs
properly but for the rest you rely on
the latent space. Okay. So this is the
the basic basic principle here. There is
some difference between the large and
small learning rates because this is a
more conservative model. This is a more
exploratory model. So that's that's
precisely the point here. And this is
not the unique way to do um finetuning.
There are also other ways but this seems
to be the most reasonable logical
scientifically valid way to do it. Okay.
So now what do you do? So this was just
exactly the exactly the same principle
as before. There's also a way to do uh
sort of time independent problems but
this is uh detailed it's not not that
important. So now let's uh try to see
what how whether this model works or
not. Right? So here is an example. Uh
this is a compressible oiler data set.
Uh reman problem with uncertain
interfaces. Uh this is how the inputs
are. So these are some initial
conditions. This is how the outputs are.
As you can see this is the ground truth
GT.
This is what the foundation model gives.
This is Poseidon
with 128 samples. This is CNO with 128
samples. And this is FNO with 128
samples. So the ground truth as you can
see is very challenging right so let's
look at the density for instance you
have shock waves so you have this
discontinuities you have all these large
and small vortices and you can also see
the shock waves very very clearly here
so it's a very challenging data set in
some sense and you see it from the fact
that if you take fn and only give it 128
samples it completely fails right you it
doesn't capture anything it's uh it's at
this data scale it's a very bad model
maybe with more data it it improves CNO
is better. This is what we have
traditionally seen. It is able to get
some information. For instance, this it
does recognize that there is a shock
here. It gets this shock very nicely.
Look at FNO for instance. It didn't even
understand that there was a shock here.
But at least it is able to get some
features, but it doesn't get all the
features. It doesn't get all the shocks,
let alone the vortices. Right? So, it's
still not a very very good model. But
the foundation model in this case,
Prooseidon, it does a very very good
job. So you can see that it gets the
vortices. It gets the shock waves. It
gets this feature very accurately. Even
this feature here which is very
difficult to capture you know it's a
triple point this feature here very
difficult to capture and it still has
been able to do it and it does it with
128 samples. Right? Because that's the
that's the key challenge. Can we bring
down the sample complexity?
Now if I started showing you these
graphs with 15 different data sets then
the whole lecture we need two lectures
just to go through that. In the paper
you can actually find all these graphs
but we have to measure the performance
based on some scores some some metrics
right and this is very important here
and uh I think we were the first to sort
of they're very obvious but no one was
doing it in this way so these are the
performance metrics so remember
everything is about scaling right as we
increase the amount of data how does the
model behave how does the error go so at
this is at the level of each downstream
task each downstream task is now
different for each of them we have
different uh choices that we can make.
So here's an example for the sheer air.
So what what what are we showing here?
So let us start uh on this right. So
what you can do is that you can run FNO,
you can run CNO, you can run Scott.
These are not foundation models. These
are task specific models. And when you
run them, you can see that as the number
of samples increases the error goes
down. So this is about um 0.01. So 0.01
is 1% error, right? Yeah. So this is 1%
error. This is uh so here to get 1%
error these models they require FNO and
uh CNO are very similar to each other.
They in this particular case they're
more or less identical and they require
about 48 or 496 samples. So that is your
B we have to fix a baseline. So the
baseline for us was FNO because FNO is
the most widely used model. So we said
that we for each of these tasks we'll
run fn with different varying number of
samples and then we define a certain
threshold let's say with,024 samples
what is the error with fno in this
particular case it is 2% right so this
is 2% error and then we say with the
foundation model how many samples
suffice to get 2% error so in this
particular case this was like a little
more than 40 samples you know so with 40
samples whatever we could do with fno
with a th00and samples
with the foundation model we could do
with the 40 samples. Right? So what does
it mean that we have a gain in terms of
sample efficiency of 25 with 25 times
better in terms of sample efficiency
with the found in this particular
example with the foundation model. So
that's one metric which is very very
important and when you are trying to
design experiments this is important
right because you have to know a
priority how many samples do you need.
So this is a very important metric. The
second metric of course is that you you
go with those number of samples that you
have. Let's say 100 samples. So again we
take FNO as the baseline. So this is
about 10% error. Now in this case you
can see the 10% error drops to something
like 1 and a.5%. Right? So this is the
gain in accuracy and both of them are
important. So one is along the x-axis
this is the sample efficiency. One is
along the y-axis is accuracy. And we
want to see over all these tasks did we
gain in terms of sample efficiency? did
you gain in terms of accuracy and if you
did that then it's worthwhile using the
foundation model because the foundation
model is trained by someone else right
means you will have access to it
hopefully to be able to use it so is
this are these metrics clear so this is
very very important to understand what
is being compared here so this is uh
essential and now we have this 15 tasks
yes go ahead
>> is it coincidence that in the beginning
is better than L
>> it's probably a coincidence you'll see
some more data about that right but this
is this is just to give you a cartoon of
what exactly are we measuring further
questions no
so as you can see and we will do a lot
of analysis of this in a second as you
can see that this is the these are the
results with respect to the 15 uh tasks
for some of them let's just focus on
poson L here the largest model right for
some of them its performance is really
amazing right it's it has a gain of 900
100 which essentially means with one
sample it is able to learn what FNO did
with,024 samples but sometimes it's more
modest for instance this one the gain is
only 3 and a half but this is really far
out of what it has seen before it's a
steady state flow across an air foil so
this is even an unstructured grid right
but on an average it does a good job so
this is what we show here so these
numbers are the average over the 15
tasks so for sample efficiency this is
the median for the error it's of course
the mean because uh you can see why we
use the median because if you use the
mean then these guys will dominate
because in some cases you have huge
sample efficiency. So on an average what
did we observe? We observed several
things. So this is a very very important
uh graph. So what did we observe that on
average across this 15 tasks the gain in
sample efficiency was a factor of 50
with the largest model. So what does it
mean? It means earlier if with FNO you
required a,000 samples you get the same
performance with 20 samples right
because 1,000 by 50 is 20 and if this
holds at large scale then our job is
solved right because we we really wanted
to find out how much we can compress
information and if we can reduce it from
10,000 samples to 100 samples which is a
factor of 50 to 200 samples then we are
done right so essentially that's the
that's the big benefit at least on these
tasks it has been able to show this
right. Similarly with respect to the
accuracy you have a gain of a factor of
10 one order of magnitude. So from 20%
error you could go down to 2% error
which is also equally good. Right? So
that's the first bottom line number.
This shows that the foundation model
works at least in this particular
setting. But there are many many other
things that you can you can look at.
Right? So what you can look at is the
scaling. So you can see that the tiny
model
is a pretty good model actually. The
tiny model it gives you a factor of 20.
This one is more like a factor of 30 and
this one is more like a factor of 50. So
there is a there is an increase in model
size as the model size increases. The
gains are increasing. They're more
modest with respect to the error but
they are still still very much there.
Right? So there is some scaling with
respect to model size which is which is
what what we want to do. That's the
first conclusion. The second conclusion
is that this was published quite a one
year back. But in the meanwhile there
have been some other foundation models.
We have not done this experiment. But at
that time there was another model uh
called deepot which was from people at
Shinhua University which is also a
foundation model. similar spirit
slightly different details just based
more on a FNO type architecture and you
can see that uh compared to that uh so
this is already 500 million this is 600
million but the size does not explain
but there is a massive gap right it's
almost twice as better as the
state-of-the-art at that time and this
model was also not very good because it
didn't scale at all with respect to
model size which is which is which is
not nice so this is a this is a
comparison there is a new model which
was released last month which claims
that it is better but we haven't yet
compared uh with that. The last point
which is very very interesting is that
if you take CNO and if you take Scott so
these are the backbones uh that we have
seen again and again as standalone
models these are things that are trained
from scratch they're both better than
FNO but they are equally good right so
in both cases they are equally good this
is also something that we have seen
before that when it comes to CNO and a
transformer there is no difference when
it comes to standalone tasks but what is
really interesting is when you train
foundation models on top of each. So
here we trained a foundation model on
top of CNO. Here we trained a foundation
model on top of Scott on of the spin
transformer. And then you can see
they're similar size. One is 100
million, the other is 150 million, but
that's that's not an issue. But you can
see here that there is a massive gain.
So this was a factor of 10. This was
almost 25. So it's 2 and a half times
better. Exactly the same data, exactly
the same training protocol, more or less
the same size just by changing the
backbone, you get benefit of two and a
half. And the reason for that is that no
one understands this why it happens. But
transformers are really the reason why
foundation models work. You know that's
why GPT is based on a transformer.
Anything is based on a vision, text,
robotics, all of it is based on a
transformer. As task specific models,
there is not a huge difference. But when
you go into this multitask multi-diverse
data set regime then there is going to
be a difference. So these were sort of
interesting interesting results by
themselves.
But now the question is let's try to
understand how this do you have any
questions about this.
>> Yes. Go ahead.
>> So the CN was the function model.
>> Yeah. And the one with transformers is
the model.
>> All the three. Yeah. The three top ones
are the but the one that you should
compare is the middle one. Right. the
second from the top because that is
similar size. So one is 110 million the
other is 158 million.
>> What's MPP?
>> MPP was a model that was released by
people at Flat Iron Institute. They have
updated it now with something called
Walrus and it did very very poorly at
that time. So
this was uh
Walrus is a better model than this but
uh this this was and this was 116
million. They have also a billion
parameter model. But it's not just a
model size that is important. As you can
see that there are some gains but these
are not the most massive gains. But why
does it work right? Means this is a
question that we should really ask
ourselves. So remember that we started
with this uh initial experiment. So this
is the ground truth. This is the
foundation model. It worked very very
well. Right? But now why does it and
this was the this was the example. It
scaled very very well in this particular
case. It's not far from the from the
physics that has been seen during
pre-training. So it is able to do a good
job. But how does it learn? So what is
very interesting here is that uh as you
can see so this is the ground truth. So
these are the different uh elements in
the ground truth right. So this is the
density this is the x velocity the y
velocity and the pressure.
And what do we have? So here you can
start with zero. You can start zero
short essentially because uh the model
has been trained on fluid flow. It has
seen fluid flow. It has seen these
variables. So you can start zero shot.
So this is zero samples, one sample, two
samples, no four samples, 32 and 128. So
this is the iterative way in which the
model learns. Right? So when you don't
show it anything, you just give it the
initial conditions and ask it to output
the velocity and the pressure and so on
and so forth, it does a pathetic job,
right? because it just does returns an
average of what it has seen before
because it has not seen this data set
before. So of course it has no clue
about what it is. It does not capture
anything essentially with one with zero
samples.
But as soon as you give it one sample,
right, one sample in this case is one
trajectory which means that it has 66
image pairs, right? Because you have
access to different uh training pairs.
Immediately it has some knowledge. It
gains some knowledge. What does it gain
in this case? It is already able to
capture this shock wave the
qualitatively not at the same location.
Also, it knows that something funky is
happening here. It knows that there's a
discontinuity here and so on and so
forth. So, even with one single sample,
the model has some scale. It is able to
do something very quickly with four
samples. It gets the shock waves correct
and it also gets the large vortices
correct. Right? This one, it does not
get the small vortices at all, but it
gets the large vortices correct. But by
32 samples, it gets everything
qualitatively correct. There, the
vortices are clear. The shocks are
clear. Even this triple point is very
nicely resolved. As you can see, not the
sharpest. That requires a little bit of
tuning. But with 128 samples, it's
almost perfect. It won't get any better.
Right? So, what we see is that
iteratively it improves on its skill. It
uses uh some of the physics that it has
learned. It cannot forget everything in
four samples and then relearn. So it
it's able to use that information that
is already there in the latent space and
is able to sort of uh find this out
right. So this is the this is the main
so it's able to assimilate data from
different sources in in the during the
pre-training process itself and you can
see it very very clearly because there
are two main features it has the three
main features I would say here. So it
has shocks it has discontinuities it has
these vortices large and small vortices.
So in principle it could learn shocks
from the pre-training data set because
there are shock waves right. So this is
um this is one of the pre-training data
sets reman problems. So you can see that
there are shock waves you can see them
very clearly here the shock waves here
shock waves here and so on. So in
principle it could learn the shock waves
from one of the models one of the data
sets that it has seen. It could learn
large vortices because uh you have large
vortices from this helm's uh Kelvin
Helm's problem. So you can see that
there are these large vortices which the
model can already learn from there. So
it can learn the shocks and it can learn
the large vortices. So these vortices
but what about the small ones here or
here so on where does it learn it from?
So our hypothesis was that it learns it
from this other it's a curve remon
problem data set where there are all
kinds of features there are shock waves
there are small features as you can see
that there are the small vortices here.
So it possibly can learn data from or
take data information from these three
models and then learn it together. This
is this is a possibility right and to
test this possibility what we did is
that we took the foundation model and we
ablated it. We took out this data set
and for parity reasons we took out a
incompressible flow data set and we kept
the same size as before not as before
but as so we have less diverse data. So
now we have four operators instead of
six but we keep the same data volume. So
what you see here is quite interesting.
So this is a half the data set diverse
and this is a less diverse data set and
you can see already that the diversity
really matters. So amount of data is the
same. The model is the same everything
is the same. But when you have a less
diverse data set you really sort of
struggle with the small vortices. For
instance you don't have the small
vortices. you don't have these kind of
small features you see these are sort of
attenuated from each other and so on and
so forth. So our sort of argument or
hypothesis here was that and you can see
here for instance this triple point this
is sort of smoothened out considerably
here. So this told us and there is some
qualitative behavior.
So on general sometimes it doesn't but
in general you see that with the half
the with the less diverse data set you
have uh consistently worse performance
you know. So this tells us that it is
able to use the data diversity as a main
road to learning these things and this
is well known in language and vision.
These are called data mixture models.
Right? So this is where it sort of
learns its different kinds of behavior
which is which is perhaps not
surprising. foundation models have been
designed to do that. But the interesting
question is what this is because this
task is not that far out of distribution
or out of the pre-training data set.
Even with one sample, we got reasonable
results, right? So it it's sort of
designed for this kind of uh kind of a
data set. But the interesting thing is
when we go completely out in in terms of
the physics, when we go wild in terms of
physics. So here is an example. So
remember that the data set that we have
or the pre-training data set is about
fluid dynamics, 2D fluid dynamics. Here
is reaction diffusion. Very very
different kinds of uh kinds of behavior.
Right? So here is the ground truth.
Things are just diffusing out, reacting,
forming patterns and so on. So you can
already see that this would be and in
fact I was pretty sure that it won't
work in this case because the the
physics is very different but the in
fact it worked very very well. So this
is with one samp this is the ground
truth with zero sample it cannot work
right because it doesn't even know that
this is reaction diffusion so you need
to change the embeddings so this is
where the finetuning really has to
happen you can't transfer everything so
you need at least one trajectory 66
samples and you can see already that
with one sample it does a pretty
reasonable job it learns reaction
diffusion it doesn't get everything but
it gets the basic features this doesn't
look like a fluid flow at all Right? And
with four trajectories, it sort of
adjusts by 32 trajectories. It's very
very good. So this is sort of the it's
in the wild somehow but still the model
is able to learn something. And to test
this further, the only way in which it
can learn is if it forgets within one
sample and then starts to relearn or it
uses its latent space information.
Right? So to do this we we went extreme.
We said okay instead of transferring the
latent space information that we did
before let's freeze it and let's just
train the embeddings. Okay. So what does
it mean that instead of having 158
tunable parameters we are just relying
on the bulk of these parameters are
still from the foundation model. We are
not training them. We are freezing them.
And all that we are training is this
293,000 parameters. So we're training uh
so this 158 million. So this is like 1%
right or less than 1% of the 150
million. So this is less than 1% of the
total parameters. So here it has no
choice but to rely on its latent
information to be able to produce
anything meaningful. Does it work in
this setting and this is very very
interesting.
So you can see of course this is what
you have seen before that when you
transfer everything it does a good job
but even when you just relearn the
embeddings within one trajectory it is
getting reaction diffusion it doesn't
get the quantities correct the colors
are off that it manages within four
trajectories but so it has to rely
entirely on its latent space to be able
to learn this problem and you can see
that that the with 32 trajectories the
error is 3% with the transferred latent
it was 1% so it was very very good. FNO
for instance is about 4%. So it is able
to with a and FNO here is about 50
million parameters in principle this has
only 200,000 parameters that is being
updated and still it is able to do a
good job right so this tells us that the
latent space the physics that has been
learned in the latent space is quite
rich. Uh the last example and this is a
very very interesting one because this
is the most extreme in a way it's a
simple problem but this is the most
extreme one that you can imagine.
This is the poson equation minus
lelassian equal to f. The operator is f
to u right it's a very simple operator
but there are many many differences. So
remember during the pre-training my
model has only seen fluid flows. It has
only seen time dependent problems. uh it
has only seen periodic boundary
conditions and the only operators that
it has seen is given initial data you
predict the trajectory of the solution.
Now here we have no fluid flow. This is
an elliptic problem. So that is not
there. It is a time independent steady
state problem. So you don't have the
time behavior at all. The input is a
forcing term. The output is the solution
rather than initial conditions the
solution. Very very different semantics
and it is directly boundary conditions.
So it is different in all possible ways
here. So even though the problem itself
is a easy one for the foundation model's
perspective, it is like shooting in the
dark. It has no it should not have any
idea of what this problem is. Right? And
in fact if you look at so this is again
um you can see this is with 128 samples.
If you take FNO for instance with 128
samples it doesn't do a very good job.
CNO is better but the foundation model
is almost perfect with 128 samples.
Right? So it is able to still learn this
quite well. How did it do this right?
Okay, these are the scalings. Uh again
we sort of freeze the latent and we look
at what the information is and this is
very very interesting. So here is
everything is transferred. So this is
transfer latent.
So remember that in the beginning I'm
just giving it three gausian right? So
the model sees three gausians.
uh it has only learned fluid flows and
has only learned initial conditions to
solution at later time right so now what
will it do and in this case the time
that we have realized is essentially
very large time because it's a steady
state problem so it should take these
three gausians move them around and
provide an average fluid flow even with
one sample it doesn't do that so what
does it do it sort of keeps the data and
slightly diffuses them out right it
keeps the data and slightly diffuses
them out even with the latent frozen
latence which is here. It still keeps
the data and slightly diffuses them out
with 16 samples and now sample is just
one data pair. It's not a is not a
trajectory, right? It's uh it's just one
data pair. So these are just 16 images
that the model sees. Here it has already
learned diffusion. Doesn't get the
quantities right but it has learned that
this is diffusion. Here on the other
hand it is also learning diffusion. You
can see that this thing is diffusing out
because the strength of the big gausian
is what uh diffuses it out. So it
diffusing out. These guys are diffusing
slightly with 128 samples. This has
already learned everything that is need
needed to be learned. This one is
already getting there. Does not get the
region correctly which it eventually
does. Right? So what does it tell us?
that physics has to be learned during
pre-training that somewhere the physics
that corresponds to uh diffusion
equation uh personal equation is hidden
inside the physics that fluid flows have
or there are many many books in the
library are different but the pages are
the same or something like that. So
there is some some sort of a
relationship there and so what does it
say that this is a viable option right
that physics is not as different as it
seems from the outside that there are
many commonalities we know that natural
language has this that's why French and
German and even bantu and swuahili they
have similar structures and because of
that uh large language models work it is
a similar analog uh observation in this
particular case uh The inference costs
of these models even the very large
models the inference costs are like 4
milliseconds not sub millisecond but 4
milliseconds. So very very fast. Uh this
is this is of course we know that and
the interesting thing and this is sort
of a key key point is that not only we
have seen this before right so that but
the model itself it always scales with
data size. So as you have more data for
the pre-training task this is the
evaluation loss you can see that the
error goes down. Similarly with the
model size as as you increase the model
size there goes down. It is slower with
respect to model size than with respect
to data size. So for very large data
sets the model size will dominate. Okay.
So this is uh these are some good
observations. Uh so what does it show?
It essentially shows that this uh
possibility of building PD foundation
models is viable that these islands or
these libraries are not totally
disconnected to each other but there are
some hidden connections by which we can
go for instance from Navia Stokes to pon
which didn't seem a priority possible
but there is this possibility that's why
this work attracted a lot of attention
and this shows that there is a
possibility of being able to reduce the
sample complexity problem of course this
was very small scale as you can imagine
It lacked 3D. It lacked um unstructured
point inputs. We only trained on fluid
dynamics. We never used diffusion models
which we know are necessary sometimes
and one of you asked we never used the
PD symbolic information. But the good
news is apart from this point that I
didn't really um didn't really elaborate
on. We know that in general we can do 3D
we can do unstructured grids. We can
train on multifysics. we can do
diffusion models and so on. So all these
can be done. So what my lab is doing at
the moment is building this at large
scale, right? And putting all these
features together. So hopefully in a few
months we'll have a large scale data set
that can the same model can predict
earthquakes, tsunamis, model clouds, uh
you know calculate uh flows past an
airplane, calculate stress on the bone
and so on and so forth. So this is
possible. uh it's not yet done but it is
it is very much possible because of the
technology that I just showed you. So I
think with that I more or less come to a
end of the course and I spend 5 minutes
just sort of updating and telling what
we wanted and what we wanted to do. So
let me just write some notes here. So
first thing is that we focused on
physics
and we assume that there are some PTE or
ODS it could be or integral differential
equations
I didn't show you examples of this but
in principle this can be done right
differential equations
which are underlying this uh which are
describing this physics they may or may
not be known sometimes they are actually
unknown and then what we wanted to do
was to learn the solution operator right
learn solution operators.
So this could be done for instance by
using pins
but we all realize that there are
limitations particularly with respect to
training the models right training is
very very nonobvious but the datadriven
approach which is what I am sort of
advocating here that works very well we
saw many many different models FNO CNO
we have transformers
and so on and for time dependent
problems We have different uh techniques
right so we have auto reggressive AR we
have all to all training time
conditioning and so on there are many
many different techniques that we saw
and we saw for unstructured grids or
point clouds this is the most
interesting thing we saw GNN's graph
neuronet networks
uh both graphs plus transformers we saw
diffusion models
and the key point was always data
efficiency,
right? Or data inefficiency rather. And
this is where foundation models come in.
Foundation models
and the course sort of covered the
entire spectrum. What we did not cover
was downstream applications, right? So
what what if you have all this you have
all these models, you have uh everything
even low sample complexity. There are
bunch of things that we can do. We can
do design
we can solve inverse problems
but I have sort of run out of time to
describe them but um you see that this
is increasingly coming out that we and
we can directly learn from observations
experiments we don't need to because
this is completely datadriven so if you
provide me experimental data we can
provide you
a representation of it right so this is
a very interesting space uh in different
applications but you can only cover so
much. So I think uh I covered what I
wanted to cover. Maybe I would have
liked one extra lecture but uh I think
it's also interesting to see something
else other than physics and this is what
David will do in the next two lectures.
We'll shift focus more to graphs and
transformers. No to graphs and
transformers they will come but it will
be in the context of chemistry and
biology and alpha fold and so on. So
that's also a very different
environment. There is much less physics
knowledge there, much less equations,
but there's a lot more data and he will
cover quite a bit of graphs,
transformers, but also diffusion models.
So that that would that would also be
very very interesting. And now some
practical information. So the the
projects will be released maybe in 2
weeks. I don't know. You'll get more
than more than a month to do them. So
and this does not just count the
Christmas uh time either. So you'll get
about a month. Uh these are not very
difficult. So do them and if you have
any questions about the course you can
always reach out to me, send me an email
and then you can come and talk to me.
Okay. So with that I stop and thank you
very much for your attention.